Paul Lucas actually does this for a
living he looks at uniforms he's the
founder and editor of Yoona watch.com
what do you think of the Cleveland
Browns new edition Dan I think it's a
great example of moving forward by going
backwards they basically went back to
their classic look which they never
really should have gone away from when
you look at these new uniforms you think
this is what the Cleveland Browns are
supposed to look like and it's sort of a
question of how did they get it so
disastrously wrong five years ago with
the set that they're now moving away
from how did the Rams get to where they
are now where you have one of their
legends Eric Dickerson who works for the
Rams railing against the Rams with their
new logo here you know the Rams have
done something that it's a little
uncommon and I think in a way is a
little unfair to the fan base and that
is instead of unveiling their entire new
identity meaning logos uniforms the
works they just did the logos and
they're going to do the uniform sometime
in May after the draft and it's not
clear they haven't said if that's
because the uniforms aren't ready yet or
they just are trying to sort of draw out
the suspense but it really isn't it does
a disservice to the fan base and I think
a disservice to your own marketing
program when you release the logos
without the full context because it's
hard you know for an NFL team a logo
could it could be appearing on your
helmet or not and you know with the Rams
probably not cos are probably going to
keep ram horns on the helmet and you
really need to see the context of these
logos and so yeah you have fans and you
have X players like Eric Dickerson
saying we don't like these logos but
really what matters is the uniform and
that best is you know the most primary
thing especially for a team like the
Rams which as I said are not going to
almost certainly not going to wear their
will go on their helmet so I think and
we're gonna have to wait and see where
that goes with the Rams
but I don't think they've done
themselves with their fan base any
favors by doing this 2-part unveiling
well what is the target demo for these
new uniforms I mean the reason why I
bring it up is the Rams aren't marketing
to me the Browns aren't marketing to me
the Atlanta Falcons aren't marketing to
my age group so hey so what if I don't
like it I'm not the one buying these
jerseys unless I'm buying it for my son
or grandson
and yeah you know then they're still
getting their money out of this so if
you were gonna say what's the sweet spot
for you know marketing these uniforms
what would it be
well I think it depends on what you
think the function of the uniform is
you're suggesting that it basically is
just a piece of merchandise and that's
certainly part of it but it's also the
thing we see when we watch a game every
Sunday it's what we you know look at and
connect with when we when we turn on the
TV and you know the famous Jerry
Seinfeld line that we're all rooting for
laundry is largely true the players come
and go they get traded they retire but
we keep rooting for that uniform no
matter which player is wearing it and
that's an important thing as well so
while you could say that you know only
the whatever the 18 to 34 year old
demographic is what you know who buys
the jerseys but they are marketing to
you they are marketing you know to me or
my dad or whoever because those are fans
as well and those are the people you
want to connect with your you know with
your team and have an emotional
attachment but I will I won't turn my
team off or pick another team because
they have a crappy uniform no but you
may feel like a little warmer and
fuzzier about it and that can pack a
trap that can translate to other things
I mean you look at teams like the
Packers or the Cowboys or you know or
the Rams for that matter you know RAM
fans and I can tell you because I hear
from a lot of them Rams fans feel really
strongly about that helmet with the you
know with the curly ram horns on it and
and they're gonna be you know II receive
and think of the NFL we feel really
strongly about NFL helmets right like
what do you have in your studio or TV
studios they have the helmets of the two
teams that are playing because that is
almost a de facto logo for an NFL team
is its helmet and we don't buy helmets
helmets are not merchandise I mean you
may buy a sticker that shows a helmet or
you know a you know a mini helmet or
something like that but in general the
helmet is not a major piece of
merchandise but it's a really important
piece arguably the cornerstone of any
team's branding visual branding program
and so I do think it goes beyond just
that the merchandise sales all right
final minute here if you ran the
Buccaneers what would you do with the
uniforms
personally I go back to the creamsicles
and bring back bucko Bruce because I
have soft spot for that
but I certainly think they'd you know
similar to the Browns they rejected the
sort of Nike approach of let's go
newfangled let's kind of break the mold
let's push the envelope and let's lead
people scratching their heads thinking
you know what the hell are you doing
there and let's go back to basics and so
they are now going back to their their
classic Super Bowl era uniform and and
again I think that's an improvement even
though it's you know a step backwards on
the timeline but I think it's a step
upwards and in terms of design quality
great to talk to you again Paul thanks
for joining us always a pleasure Dan
thanks Paul Lucas founder and editor of
yoona watch dot-com